les voyageurs les surnomme les îles
enchantées une quarantaine de gros
caillou posé au beau milieu du pacifique
à 1000 km des côtes équatoriennes
un archipel isolé qui offre une faune et
une flore d'une diversité
exceptionnelles
les français qui vivent sur cette terre
du bout du monde se comptent sur les
doigts d'une main fabienne 41 ans et
guides naturalistes
et voici son bureau
un
bateau de croisière qui naviguent d'îles
en îles
elle accompagne des groupes de
vacanciers tout à l'heure
aline 30 ans a fondé une agence de
voyage il ya cinq ans aujourd'hui elle
accueille une famille française à
l'aéroport
bonjour bienvenue 7e rallye mais tous
nos balises
c'est elle qui s'est occupée de
l'organisation de leur séjour aux
galapagos
sur le continent où william lui se
consacre à un autre trésor de l'équateur
la forêt amazonienne et ses habitants
des tribus indiennes
camille pin tastet six mois ça ce sont
les peintures de guerrier oui c'est marc
signifie que tu es quelqu'un de valeur
williams aline et fabienne trois
français qui ont tout quitté pour vivre
dans un pays où la nature est reine
oui
le galapagos les jambes s'approche de
l'île de bartolomé le tourisme aux
galapagos est très encadrée c'est l'un
des 140 bateaux autorisés à organiser
des croisières dans l'archipel
à son bord une centaine de passagers et
des guides naturalistes
parmi eux une française
15 minutes nous allons commencer le
département pour un commandant chaussée
de chaussures style tennis
nous avons aussi des bâtons de marche à
notre disposition enquête est désarmant
fabienne et guy de galapagos depuis cinq
ans des commandes sera le premier à
débarquer suivi par le groupe des
albatros merci beaucoup quinze minutes
après
ce matin elle emmène ses croisiéristes
en excursion sur l'un des 40 îlots de
l'archipel
j'ai encore quatre places
donnez moi la main voilà parfait
avant de sauter d'un bateau à l'autre à
longueur d'année fabienne été groupe
hier dans un casino d'aix-en-provence
désormais elle passe vingt jours par
mois en mer
c'est génial on en rencontre elle a mis
tous les jours et on n'est jamais
fatigué de ce qu'on fait en fait parce
qu'on voit jamais la même chose il ya un
manchot s'est
il doit faire une trentaine de
centimètres il est tout petit c'est la
plus petite espèce de manchots au monde
un manchot qui ne s'enfuit pas ici les
animaux savent qu'ils n'ont rien à
craindre des humains
le groupe débarque à bartholomé une île
n'est d'une éruption volcanique il y a
cinq millions d'années au beau milieu du
pacifique un décor qui a fait basculer
le destin de fabienne qui m'a fait
regretter c'est que j'ai je suis arrivé
aux galates aguas j'ai eu le coup de
foudre pour les galapagos est
une des façons pour être le plus près de
la nature et des animaux c'est de cette
sphère guide naturaliste ici
fabienne a dû passer un concours
effectué une formation sur le terrain
pour tout apprendre de la faune et la
flore locales elle est aujourd'hui la
seule française parmi les 500 guides du
parc
cecon ici qu'on a autour de nous en
français on les appelle la déconne forme
blues de vache c'est pas très joli le
nombre c'est comme ça qu'on les attend
quand les appels en fait c'est lorsqu'on
a une éruption volcanique la lave qui
est assez fluide et éjecté dans l'air et
retombe en éclaboussant donc sur le sol
les ils n'ont plus de secret pour elle
350 marches plus haut au sommet de
bartolomé il semblerait que fabienne et
déjà réussi à transmettre à son groupe
bien plus que des données géologiques
quand on voit des paysages pareil on se
dit qu'on peut tomber sous le charme
beauté du paysage est unique il ya une
palette de couleurs c'est magnifique
et le plus beau est à venir sur les îles
mais aussi sous l'eau
la première visite s'achève par une
baignade dans une eau turquoise
saga qui sont à paris en ce moment
les galapagos sont réputés dans le monde
entier pour la richesse de leur zone
on y trouve plus de 300 espèces de
poissons différentes
cette réserve marine est inscrite sur la
liste du patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité
et fabienne en profitent le plus souvent
possible
pendant ce temps à l'autre bout de
l'archipel aline attaque sa journée de
travail
travailler en bateau
ça va ça sympa ça change du métro
aline a quitté la franche comté pour
fonder une agence de voyages aux
galápagos ce matin elle va retrouver la
famille de touristes qu'elle a accueilli
à l'aéroport
ici quand il ya un ralentissement sur le
chemin ce n'est pas à cause des
embouteillages
ma mère
jusqu'à l'âge d'or en fait ça
vous voulez la peau une baleine avec
avec son pied en fait
impressionnant que son buste là
aline arrive dans le port de santa cruz
la capitale des galapagos c'est ici
qu'elle a organisé la première excursion
pour ses clients
[Musique]
la famille ferrone bac arrive de région
parisienne elle ne passe que quatre
jours aux galapagos aline ne veux pas
leur faire perdre une minute
c'est un moqueur il est très jeune est
au bout du chemin une plage vierge de
plusieurs kilomètres la plus célèbre de
l'archipel à part le petit port toute
l'île est inconstructible cela fait
partie des mesures draconiennes pour
protéger les seuls habitants des lieux
des centaines d'iguane
boga doudou
étonnant 10 25
petits dinosaures c'est
et ces gros ici with un gros ventre
images des algues
les crèches les selles
c'est iguane qui ont la particularité de
savoir nager peuvent atteindre un mètre
de long une espèce qui n'existe nulle
part ailleurs dans le monde et qui doit
être protégé c'est pas une destination
de tourisme de masse dont sera jamais
les uns sur les autres à la plage c'est
ça qui fait le charme des zilin faciale
ce soit exclusif s'il ya trop de monde
qui vient ça va être sa vague à celle
des animaux devront changer leurs
comportements certaines espèces va être
en danger donc il faut arriver à le
protéger et ça veut dire ne pas avoir
trop de tourisme en fait
après la plage aline emmène ses clients
dans son agence
elle a prévu une après-midi de plongée
en mer
c'est bon tu as besoin d'un tuba ça
pendant qu'ils s'équipent aline monte
peaufiner le planning
laon pas partie plus administrative ou
à 30 ans sa petite entreprise marche
bien donc et si on a les bureaux
ça c'est le tableau où on a toujours par
jour tous les passagers qui sont avec
nous en fait le principe de c1 saison
s'appelle vraiment klein c1 est très
occupée selon les mois elle a entre 150
et 350 clients
restent eux ce sont les factures de juin
et juillet mais alors oui celle du mois
d'août
lorsqu'elle arrive sur l'île elle a 25
ans un bts de tourisme et beaucoup
d'énergie au début des fois c'était
hallucinant la différence de culture en
était
nous on est quand même assez sur le
boulot stricte et ou pas mais ici j'ai
foi c'est
tranquille c'est un peu stressant ça
fait des sueurs froides passé ouais
aujourd'hui elle emploie 7 personnes et
a tiré un trait sur le mode de vie à la
française les gens voient la même vie
que moi c'était à mon âge ils ont déjà
forcé d'acheter des maisons à crédit la
voiture alors que moi je suis vraiment
tout ce à quoi c'est quand je rentre ça
fait des conversations voilà ma chute à
faire le marqueur j'étais nager et non
non mais voilà celle des c'est vraiment
indifférent quand aline ne regrette rien
sauf parfois sa famille restée dans sa
franche comté natal à 11000 km sur un
petit bout de caillou mais du pacifique
et puis voilà quoi on est un peu usé
finalement même si les visionner
internet et on sent un petit peu dans un
autre monde un monde qu'elle s'est
donnée pour mission de faire découvrir
et partager
aline comme fabienne sont les
sentinelles d'une nature précieuse et
fragile qui doit être protégé
mais il n'ya pas que les galapagos qui
font l'objet de toutes les attentions en
equateur
sur le continent le pays possède un
autre trésor une partie de la forêt
amazonienne
l'équateur est le seul pays au monde à
avoir inscrit le respect de la nature
dans sa constitution celle ci a des
droits et pour les faire respecter elle
peut compter sur un autre français
william ouaddou était ingénieur en
télécommunications à asnières il a
abandonné cdi et pavillon de banlieue il
y à 12 ans pour venir vivre au chevet de
l'amazonie
la forêt amazonienne a toujours tiré
[Musique]
dégage un certain mystère en fait que
j'apprécie énormément l'équateur c'est
justement ce contact proximité avec une
nature absolument puissante qui
jacky presse qui n'a pas d'équivalent ce
matin ils quittent quito la capitale où
il réside pour une expédition en pleine
forêt amazonienne
il emporte de quoi y vivre en
autosuffisance pendant quatre jours
alors on n'a plus rien là
seul moyen de transport un petit avion
peu engageant quand approche et une
tempête tropicale
s'est pas trop humide là dessous non ça
va aller
ok comment s'annonce le vol plus mieux
le départ simplement mais je pense
qu'après n'y aura pas de souci il m'a
l'air malgré les quelques coups en bon
état
[Musique]
william est un habitué c'est son 30e
voyage en amazonie
[Musique]
après quelques minutes de vol
première éclaircie
l'amazonie se dévoile
c'est clairement un rêve ça rêve
d'enfant que pouvoir survoler ces
immenses étendues et d'y pénétrer un
moment ou un autre
si en équateur la nature a des droits
ils sont très souvent violées l'amazonie
équatorienne subi la plus forte
déforestation au monde à ce rythme il
n'y aura plus de forêts en équateur dans
60 ans
on peut voir d'ailleurs là regardez il
ya une parcelle en train de la passer là
c'est un exemple flagrant de
déforestation qu'un jour cette forêt va
disparaître ou ne sera plus qu'un petit
oui hier j'ai à dire william relève
l'épreuve et réunit des témoignages dans
les villages d'indiens pour mobiliser
les politiques à quito la capitale
après une heure de vol il arrive à court
ni de ça une poignée d'habitations
isolées de tous aucune route aucun
fleuve ni même
pour l'atterrissage pas de tour de
contrôle
et même de piste en dur
nous y voilà
bonjour
bonjour bienvenue merci
williams s'est déjà rendu dans plusieurs
tribus d'amazonie il sait qu'avant toute
chose il doit se plier à un rituel bien
locale
le partage d'une boisson traditionnelle
la chicza préparés à base de racines de
manioc fermenté
alors là ça risque de vous effrayer un
peu
à savoir que les femmes en fait mach le
le manioc et leur crache et donc c'est
la salive cela permet de la fermentation
en fait de la boisson plusieurs
exactement au plus la dame est vieille
meilleur et le la préparation
cours ni de sa regroupe une trentaine de
familles membres de la tribu shiwiar
leur mode de vie et traditionnelle il
pêche chasse écueil ce qu'ils trouvent
pour se nourrir seule concession à la
modernité des avions livre parfois des
vêtements ou de l'essence pour le
générateur du village
les gisements de pétrole ont été
découverts non loin sur le territoire
qu'ils occupent et depuis les civières
craignent d'être expulsé
bonjour à tous
william des comptes les derniers puits
d'exploitation creusée sur le territoire
shiwiar par les compagnies pétrolières
est repéré par le chef de la tribu
il y en a 1 brède ce village là à thoune
guide ça
est un autre la vertu india
mais tu pense qu'ils vont arriver
jusqu'ici et quand elles tm pour wii
avec le temps mais nous ne voulons pas
que les compagnies pétrolières viennent
occuper nos terres les gens ici sont
vraiment soucieux de défendre leur
territoire
leschi viard vivent sur ces terres
depuis toujours mais ils n'ont jamais eu
de titre de propriété
williams veut les aider à les obtenir
pour que personne à l'avenir depuis ce
les chasser
dans la chance de partager les données
de l'environnement qui ne vivent
cette nature tout le monde fabuleuse je
pense qu'il faut des accompagnants fait
dans cette lutte pour défendre cet
environnement privilégié exceptionnel
donc donc moi ça oui ça me tient à coeur
je trouve que c'est une c'est une lutte
noble le message de william est entendu
au sommet de l'état demain une ministre
doit venir jusqu'ici annoncé
officiellement si oui ou non les
compagnies pétrolières pourront forer
dans les environs un moment attendu par
tous les villageois mieux vraiment
magnifique
william partage le quotidien des indiens
dans la jungle il retrouve les
sensations les paysages qu'il attache à
ces lieux
c'est le ba locale effectivement c'est
le seul endroit de façon peu d'amour
cette nuit il s'endormira face au
coucher de soleil au coeur de cette
amazonie qu'il veut préserver à tout
prix
dans l'autre paradis équatorien des
galapagos fabienne la guide naturaliste
poursuit ses excursions par l'une de ses
villes préférées
ça peut être glissant attention hein
ville de seymour un condensé de
biodiversité sur deux petits kilomètres
carrés une arche de noé grandeur nature
ok tonnes de carbone écoutez moi s'il
vous plaît c'est très important que vous
restiez toujours groupé
les conditions de visite sont très
strictes lille n'a jamais été habité par
l'homme elle est à l'état brut halfon
2000 rien de regarder elle est immense
ils ont l'envergure très très importante
à les frégates et ça leur est difficile
en fait date et rien sur les arbustes
faut pas s'attendre à voir des milliers
et des milliers d'espèces
ce qui est important dans les paroisses
équidés des espèces la rareté de
l'espèce qui est important ici des
espèces qu'on ne trouve pas ailleurs
l'accès à ce sanctuaire un temps classée
sites en péril est désormais limité à
quelques personnes par jour
on sent que c'est pas organisé entre
guillemets pour les touristes comme dans
beaucoup de communes dans beaucoup de
pays ici bas on voit les animaux les
voit on les voit pas on les voit pas ils
font ce qu'ils veulent s'ils veulent
venir vers nous y viennent s'ils veulent
pas amer c'est leur choix ça ça me plaît
sa caméra marché bientôt derrière moi a
transmis
la couleuvre là
il n'y a jamais une exploitation humaine
aux galapagos donc nos animaux n'ont pas
développé une grande convergence c'est
incroyable de voir les oiseaux d'aussi
près quoi ils n'ont pas n'ont pas peur
de l'homme et si on était ailleurs il
semblerait à tire d'aile mais papa que
les oiseaux les mammifères les les
reptiles que ça je crois que c'est c'est
uniquement moi donc légalement et est un
des derniers trésors naturels aux
galapagos les guides naturalistes sont
les gardiens des lieux ils doivent faire
appliquer à la lettre les règles du parc
national
interdiction de fumer d'utiliser un
flash peut faire du bruit ou des
mouvements brusques et surtout de sortir
de l'unique centimes
ces deux là madame s'il vous plaît pas
plus loin
au chemin au centre
absolument respecter les limites c'est
pourquoi
sinon on peut déjà fait à neuf la
touques est tombé au caire - pour que ça
caille au
losc est tombé là
c'est vrai parce qu'on peut détruire des
nids vous pour marcher son soin des
animaux sans les voir or tout simplement
après une heure sur place le petit
groupe doit partir de lille pour laisser
la place aux suivants
ce que je ressens une paix totale
c'est magnifique
et vierge tout est intact il me semblait
mal à l'aise de laisser mes empreintes
dans le sable comme si je perturbais
tout ça
j'ai énormément de chance d'avoir pu
venir ici
fabienne leur a réservé une dernière
surprise une rencontre avec des lions de
mer
cela se repose mais au large les plus
chanceux peuvent les voir en pleine
action
de très près
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en compagnie d'aline la famille ferrone
bac espère bien en croisé cet après midi
et là c'est là où va la roche la boxe la
plaine dormido comme le lion endormi en
fait parce qu'il trouve que ça ressemble
à une otarie
[Musique]
une frégate
ici les animaux pour leur place est en
fête
des animaux qui nous regardent
bizarre
la danse est c'est l'or noir
assad à prouver
[Musique]
cyril le père de famille se prépare pour
une heure de plonger avec un masque et
un tuba on va plonger d'ici et le bateau
ne récupère de l'autre côté la neige va
être facilitée avec le courant ça va
nous porter un
sous l'eau pas encore de lions de mer
mais des requins accueille les plongeurs
alors la première petite impression
la presse grecque
un banc de pointe blanche passe quelques
mètres plus bas une espèce inoffensive
qui vit près des récifs la première fois
qu'on les voit au début on se dit mais
qu'est ce que c'est ce poisson grille
tout au fond la herpe l'on se dit mais
c'est un requin est en fait vont tout
doucement ils passent tous calmement
ocha
il
les plongeurs remonte vers le bateau
quand un compagnon de jeu surgit
une otarie
elles font des gestes calme dans un
internat l'impression qu'elles sont très
fluides qu'elles se
déplacent tout en douceur dans l'eau et
elle vont très vite en même temps quand
elle les accélère d'un coup mais juste
un tout petit mouvement est appelé
accélère c'est très amusant
[Musique]
pour mettre ses projets
les marchés
trouvait qui eût veille
j'entends déjà tendue
elle est de taille et bien sûr avec nous
c'est une super sensation unique concert
à l'accent c'est celle unique
[Musique]
pour finir la journée ali normes et de
la famille dîner chez des amis un
traîneau en prime un couple de pêcheurs
de l'île
elle est grosse
[Musique]
les invités ont de la chance la pêche à
la langouste n'est autorisé que quatre
mois dans l'année et en petites
quantités
demain après quatre jours aux galápagos
ils repartent en france
dans la forêt amazonienne tout le monde
attend l'arrivée de la ministre la tribu
indienne va bientôt savoir si elle est
expulsable ou si elle garde son
territoire convoité par les compagnies
pétrolières
tous les membres des tribus alentours
convergent vers cour me de ca certains
ont fait plus de cinq heures de marche
dans la forêt pour assister à
l'événement
une délégation officielle arrive de la
capitale à bord de cet avion la ministre
de l'environnement
[Musique]
williams retrouve des collaborateurs
qu'il connaît bien
bonjour comment allez vous
rien ça va être un jour historique oui
ça fait huit ans qu'ils attendent cette
visite
la ministre et sa délégation apporte une
grande nouvelle aux membres des tribus
indiennes
et william est aux premières loges
[Applaudissements]
depuis trop d'années vous vivez sans
aucun papier officiel sans titre de
propriété pour ces terres qui sont les
vôtres votre peuple est un peuple
millénaire et aujourd'hui le
gouvernement vous reconnaît reconnais
vos droits vous êtes propriétaire et
personne ne pourra vous prendre vos
terres
[Applaudissements]
c'est un plaisir pour moi cette
reconnaissance est une révolution qui
s'est déroulé pacifiquement la joie que
vous éprouvez aujourd'hui je la partage
[Applaudissements]
la tribu devient officiellement
propriétaire de 110 mille hectares de
forêt c'est le fruit de huit années de
travail de persuasion de recherche
d'informations de levée de fonds pour
williams et ceux qui l'ont accompagné
dans son combat alors voilà le fameux
document comment tout ça super
quel moment génial
merci à toi williams
c'est un message à d'autres populations
indiennes pour voir que le combat est
toujours possible parce que parfois
effectivement quand on s'affronte à des
géants comme est peut-être lié comme des
états qui ont plein de pouvoirs c'est
difficile d'obtenir gain de cause donc
là on est en train de démontrer qu'il
est possible d'avoir ce type de résultat
et de protéger la forêt aussitôt la
cérémonie terminée la délégation
ministérielle regagne quito
williams reste encore quelques jours
avec le sentiment d'avoir contribué à
sauver une petite parcelle d'amazonie
n'aurait pas aimé me lever à 40 ans en
disant mais qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que
je vais raconter à mes enfants qu'est-ce
qu'elle était ma vie en fait et là je
sens qu'aujourd'hui j'ai plein
d'expériences nouvelles de plein de
choses que je pourrais passer en fait à
mes enfants et ça ça me seulement ça me
réjouit mais en plus j'y vois vraiment
un sens
[Musique]
aux galapagos le bateau de fabienne hfc
quatre jours de croisière
la guide française va quitter son groupe
au revoir
à une prochaine fois
elle regagne pour quelques jours lille
où elle habite en attendant le prochain
départ c'est l'une des très rares zones
constructibles de l'archipel une petite
ville de 2000 habitants
wallace pavillon
bien qu'est-ce que je te sers du chorizo
ça m'a fait plaisir de te voir anthony à
plus tard fabienne repart en bateau dans
quelques jours mais la mère du manque
déjà
les galapagos et la mer
à la mer sans n'avoir pas pendant
plusieurs journées n'est pas bien
c'est le respect et le respect de la
nature le respect de dame nature voilà
c'est ça et aux galapagos et il est plus
fort qu'ailleurs donc vous il ya
possibilité de cohabiter avec la nature
avec des animaux c'est rare mais honda
la fin c'est possible ou sera t-elle
dans 5 ou 10 ans fabien ne le sait pas
elle n'est pas pressée de rentrer en
france à chacun de ces tours dans
l'archipel elle découvre de nouvelles
merveilles
aline s'accordent une journée de détente
avec ses amis équatorien elle est membre
d'un club de surf qui se réunit une fois
par semaine
dans les vagues son petit ami carlos
natif des galapagos
aujourd'hui elle a une bonne raison de
ne pas se mettre à l'eau
non je peux pas là en ce moment super
talent vient ça va quoi si on a un petit
équatorien ou un petit portrait un petit
mélange des deux ça va être bien ça veut
dire que vous êtes définitivement
installé ici
ouais ouais je pense que c'est un signe
que on est encore là pour quelques
années
pour quelque temps à line va limiter les
glissades sur l'eau et les excursions en
bateau mais après la naissance de son
bébé elle compte bien se rattraper et du
faire découvrir le paradis où il va
avoir la chance de grandir
[Musique]